[Musique]
la tarte au sucre a un dessert qu'on
commande régulièrement dans les
restaurants familiaux qui va sûrement se
retrouver sur une tablée des fêtes dans
quelques temps parce que celle de nos
grands-mères est souvent la meilleure
mais on en achète encore beaucoup à
l'épicerie et d'ailleurs on a voulu
savoir laquelle était la préférée de
notre public entre la Saint-Hubert la
Saint-Donat celle de la tartrerie du
verger des musées ou encore la sélection
du boulanger du CF marché des promenades
à Saint-Bruno place à la dégustation
[Musique]
avec la crème glacée à la vanille
quand on regarde le tableau de la valeur
nutritive elle se compare
à la maison
moi pas du tout je les achète en fait
vous ouais
[Musique]
une tarte au sucre est composée tout
d'abord d'une pâte qui prennent pas de
brisée une pâte à tarte qu'on appelle
dans le langage commun et on peut
retrouver certaines avec une pâte sucrée
donc une pâte qui est un peu plus ferme
donc un peu plus craquante effrayable
donc ici on a plusieurs sortes de tartes
différentes on a des tables qui sont
couvertes donc avec une pâte sur le
dessus une pâte au fond ici aussi mais
on appelle ça riz au lait donc c'est
quadrilé une garniture qui va être à
base de cassonade essentiellement il va
y avoir parfois des œufs parfois non il
va y avoir de la crème si on utilise une
crème 18% ou une crème 35% la différence
c'est qu'une 35 % on va avoir une
garniture qui va être plus onctueuse
c'est sûr et certain
[Musique]
sur 10 je mettrai 8 ça c'est celle que
j'aime tu peux qu'est-ce qu'elle a de
c'est bon ben moi je trouve c'est le
côté caramel c'est fondant comme le côté
sucré et comme présent mais pas trop
sur le dessus non plus
une croûte à la marguerite donc à la
margarine on n'a pas l'aspect de Grot
qui nous reste en bouche dans le palais
donc c'est la croûte que je trouve qui
est plus agréable au bout
[Musique]
la texture on dirait que le goût sucré
un petit peu plus authentique aussi que
les autres j'ai l'impression que ça
serait quasiment fait de faire ma
grand-mère mais ça me fait pas vraiment
penser une tarte au sucre mais c'est pas
mauvais
je pense que moi
des différences de couleurs après ça
dépend de la proportion de cassonade
qu'on va y mettre par rapport à la crème
plus qu'on vient mettre de crème ça va
pas lire un peu c'est là il n'y a pas de
crème une tarte au sucre qui ne contient
pas de crème peut quand même une tarte
au sucre parce qu'elle est les mêmes
principales il faut qu'il y ait du sucre
donc la cassonade comme tel donc oui un
peu de considéré comme une tarte au
sucre
[Musique]
vraiment bonne [ __ ]
je trouve ça
que j'aime
la texture la porte
pour le peu de garniture à l'intérieur
donc si comme la pâte est au est au gras
donc ça va être moins agréable au goût
mais la garniture elle est très jolie
celle que vous trouvez qui ressemble
davantage
on l'identifie comme ça tarte au sucre à
la crème c'est sûr quand on dit tarte au
sucre à la crème ben on s'attend d'avoir
de la crème à l'intérieur
[Musique]
les carrés de sucre ce matin
la garniture se tient bien aussi c'est
pas trop coulant donc on pourrait la
chauffer celle-ci et on aurait quand
même quelque chose qui tiendrait donc on
peut regarder à Landau on voit la croûte
ici là ok donc il manque un peu de
cuisson mais si vous la réchauffez un
peu ça va l'aider mais c'est sûr
qu'industriellement il devrait la cuire
un petit peu plus quand même
juste la moitié de la bouche trop
tardes les gens aiment la tarte au sucre
qu'elles soient à l'ancienne à la crème
ou simplement au sucre trois marques ont
été à peu près exégos mais il y en a une
qui c'est nettement démarquée c'est la
Saint-Hubert à l'ancienne peut-être
parce qu'elle ressemble beaucoup à celle
de vos mères ou grand-mère mais en tout
cas ça a été la préférée de nos
goutteurs aujourd'hui mais profitez-en
sucré vous le bec pendant le temps des
fêtes
[Musique]